yesterday yeah that's why he's such a
great champion because he's so
passionate and
okay we're off we do have a kingsport
opening both sides pushing it there
pawns in front of the king's two squares
the knights develop and
magnus brings his bishop out this is the
italian game one of the most popular
openings in chess one of the most
topical
openings in chess and magnus um just
bringing a knight out now
black has castled his king that is what
we recommend
in all chess games but magnus delaying
that decision will magnus try and
attack the black king later on and okay
we've seen a trade of pawns in the
center
both knights now jumping forward white's
knight attacking the black bishop which
has retreated
white finally does castle and he stated
when he played in the new and chess
classic that he wanted to play in san
francisco it's a place he's never been
to
or he wants to be there and okay we'll
have some moves on the board
hikaru has retreated the night and the
bishop has stepped
back and now we're deviating
from a game that hikaru actually played
with the black pieces against uh topolof
in 2019.
bishop you have to keep your lights
going bishop it's one of white's
best pieces and okay nakamura now
developing his light squad bishop as
well
the pawn on the left side of the board
move it two squares
and uh yep this is the main move and
it's actually
i have to apologize i misread my my
statistics
if that white pawn is able to move again
it would dislodge black's knight
it would be very annoying black's
already moved that night three times he
doesn't want to have to lose
even more uh moves dealing with that
problem piece so okay he does
in the end push his own pawn stopping
white's advance it will start to move
towards other parts of the board
and magnus doesn't hesitate he develops
his bishop just with the speed with
which
magnus has been playing his moves it's
clear he has studied this exact position
he predicted this arriving on the board
move a queen
retreat your bishop okay hikaru
surprises
uh maybe even magnus by moving his king
that's a bit of a mysterious one but the
black king
was on the same diagonal as one of
white's bishops so that's
a bit of a kind of cautious move a
cautious approach
that white bishop now not eyeing up that
black king and
therefore maybe the pawn later will be
uh
it will be possible to push a pawn yeah
yeah well okay we have had a move we
have a plan from
magnus he's centralized his rick and uh
well hikaru is we kind of said that he's
been playing
safety first approach he's uh very happy
with just
halving out coasting through until the
next into the knockout stages i'm
expecting magnus just simply to pick up
the knight in the center
and then just move it towards the left
and uh i like that move
primarily because it's a forward move
and i uh
okay he plays a backward move instead
the timing of that was
incredible not what you expected your
anchor queen bishop
you choose david okay he doesn't but if
he had taken with the queen
let's just show that um this is only a
temporary pawn sacrifice so black is one
of pawn but the whole idea is after a
series of trades
everything coming off the board at the
very end white would regain the pawn
white could take black central pawn
the tournament situation is playing on
your mind and you really
really want to win and often this
results in making some psychological
choices like you
force the play and here we can actually
see that magnus
has played the move that david suggested
counted in the center
and uh well the big issue here is will
hikaru do as david recommended and just
push forward his pawn and uh make some
very awkward threats
uh scary stuff it's the best move hikaru
he plays
this pawn push and now how is magnus
gonna deal with this threat
it's scary times he might actually have
to find a way to sacrifice something
just to stay in the game we need to
bring up the player cameras because i
have to see how
uh magnus is reacting to that
and uh still calm still calm very calm
magnus reacts very aggressively he just
decides to do
a counter attack in the center against
the black knight i mean it's just
inevitable that those pawns are going to
advance and
okay magnus retreats his bishop the
whole way that's not the type of move he
would have enjoyed playing
but it was just a necessary uh necessary
movement
okay that worked it's very very wow
david we're wrong and magnus
is surprised by that one we saw him lean
forward he looks more interested now
magnus magnus carson he looks surprised
by that decision i i'm really shocked by
that actually because uh
now magnus gets to square for his
knights exactly and that's a almost like
a free move
on the board you know if he just moved
his bishop just to solidify those two
pawns i mean
again the issue would have been on
hikaru what are you going to do
and hikaru just moves his knight and
now of course he develops but uh this is
i i just feel this is the magnus effect
nakamura
against everyone else in the world he
would have just maintained the tension
he knew that the opponent doesn't have
any easy moves he would have just
defended his pawns and said okay
i've got a strategic advantage you do
nothing you can do nothing
but now he pushed forward he's given
white a fantastic night in the middle of
the board now
and look at magnus's last move just
bringing the bishop back defending this
knight in the center of the board white
has a beautiful piece that's an outpost
for the night that can never be removed
by a pawn you gotta let your opponent
show
their strengths
and i mean that in a bit of a mean way
yeah i mean pawns they just control more
squares when they're side by side they
control
everything and now uh by the fact that
black did advance one of them it means
the other
pawn is a backward pawn uh it means it's
weaker they control fewer squares
between them and
nakamura he's had to take a sidestep
with the black rook there but
that looks like a bit of a mysterious
one he does push upon he gets ready
to put his dark squared bishop on a
better diagonal
that dark squared bishop for white was
boxed in we did see it retreat back to
its star square a few moves ago
and now it is destined for a better now
using the light squared bishop to
capture that knight because
that light squared bishop is an
important piece i do think black should
have used his knight in the corner we
say knights on the rim are dim
black's knight in this on the side there
on that left-hand side it's not doing
anything
he should have brought it towards the
center but instead he's improved his
bishop well i say improved he's moved
his bishop at least
but it's just staring at its own pawn
that his bishops blocked in and now
white's bishop finds a dream diagonal
ivanka mentioned that bishop wanted to
go to that square anyway but now it's
even stronger because the black bishop
cannot trade it off well john is my
general perception of him okay we have
to take this move
hikaru has rearranged the night so it's
attacking the pawn
but okay this is uh a very easy you hate
it
yeah look magnus now pushing forward the
black knights
they've earlier they were perfectly
centralized black's knights
have spent four or five moves just
pushing themselves off to that left side
of the board
where they have no influence at all and
now magnus he sensed that this is the
right moment he's pushing forward
if we see a trade of pawns now okay we
don't see a trader boards but if we had
seen a trader pawns white's knight would
have jumped into the position but that's
a
huge pawn uh david in the new and chess
classic finals and uh did you ever allow
a porn like that to survive
no no no no i mean i mean just look at
it especially if it gets protected by
another pawn
that is a monster pawn you know two
squares away from
queenie and as david very importantly
highlights that pawn
cuts the black position in half which is
actually i often take this as a signal
like a red flag
for the opponent to start attacking that
thought pawn is going to be a thorn in
his side forever
and nakamura he continues to maneuver
his pieces but that knight came from
that square
two moves ago he's lost so much time um
sometimes
especially i noticed in rapid and blitz
chess you just look move by move and you
forget
what's happened in the last few turns
but if nakamura if he goes back and
analyzes this game he'll realize how
much time he's lost with his knights
all of the white pieces are perfectly
placed all of them pointing towards the
center as well
okay nakamura he tries to pin one of one
of the white knights
that black bishop just trying to annoy
um annoying magnus
magnus calling nakamura annoying earlier
that's an annoying type of move
but it's a very short-term thing i mean
there's no opponent you can't make it
easy
and you have to create some chaos on the
board
and uh um magnus he's not phased he
instead is just advancing on the left
side
and almost trapped that black knight on
the edge of the board
and we do see a trade of pawns there
okay and nakamura
top top off the table at the moment but
he does bring his queen out to the left
side so finally activating a piece but
i'm not sure whether that queen is
actually on a great square with
the time that they do have left yes
there is certainly a lot of pieces okay
but we do
have a critical decision from magnus he
while he has pushed upon to attack the
knight and
uh was this what this wasn't the move
that i was expecting i was expecting
magnus to kind of keep the tension a
little bit more on the position
and uh hikara just captures the pawn so
now what
okay michael recaptures it would have
been tempting to take the queen yeah i
wanted to
suggest that one okay but uh magnus
decides to capture with a pawn
and uh what is hikari going to do with
his knight
so black's knight now on the side of the
board it is attacked it retreats
oh dear it's not the second time it
retreats original square
yes exactly this is a real like visual
indication that things have
gone wrong i mean hikaru you're tied up
you can barely move a piece
and it kind of retreats that night well
the other night again
um those nights i'll be interested to
count how many times they've moved but
both of them back
on the uh on the starting row now magnus
is that the position is
so good and this is a move that i really
wanted to play actually
i wanted to retreat the night because i
was there visualizing the night coming
to the center
to attack the queen and just push the
push the black pieces even
more and uh i was going to say but
magnus is completely not fussed about
this is that there's a lot of choice
black's retreating again it's as if he
well i mean we might even see the bishop
starts retreating but everything else is
on the back row
and look at that night it's jumped into
the heart of white uh heart of the black
position it's going to jump
even further in i mean it's been very
one-sided the last
dozen moves and it's all to do with that
pawn move i mean
it's just like i started downward
downward spiral path for
hikaru okay hikaru trying finally to get
one piece active at least the black rook
came down pinning the white bishop but
that black rook is getting attacked now
exactly and it just handed a move to
magnus magnus is like fine i'm gonna
attack it away and so that all
hikari can do is just retreat his rook
no matter where it goes it's going to
get captured
it's going to get trapped uh it
sacrifices itself for a bishop
um so now magnus is a rook for a bishop
up and white still has that powerful
pawn
white still has a beautiful knight in
the center of the board yes black has
been able to
ruin the pawn structure of round white's
king but there are no pieces to attack
that white king that's the key
and uh well magnus just moves forward
with his knight to attack the rook yep
so black's rook now likely to move
um which square will he choose he's got
two safe squares that black brook
he just slides one square across a cross
keeping an eye on that white passport
when you're defending such a miserable
position like this you must never ever
lose hope and the hope that i see for
hikaru is if
i manage to get the knight that's on the
right
out you know two squares to the right
and then we have a checkmating threat
you want to scare the opponent and
that's just defensive
i'm not really a big fan of his last
move
because it does interfere with the
coordination between the rook
minimal okay okay one of the nights
i wanted him to move his knight to the
right and white would have challenged
the black queen
oh like that okay he brings his queen in
i said he was looking for a way in he
finds one with the white queen i still
don't see what the threat is
but both sides playing those kind of
scary types of moves right
look like he's uh winning orianna pogba
that's dramatic for nepo
geary maybe he's winning against one of
the tournament leaders to
timor ajabov and okay we do have a move
and
magnus has stepped up with a rook i'm a
little bit nervous about the
clock situation because that is ticking
and hikaru finally moves a knight
to the right side of the board and
starts getting ready for some action so
there is a threat in the position he's
gonna be calculating he's pushing the
white pawn forward
one square okay he ignores black's
threat he just brings the white bishop
back
and he's eyeing up black's pawn in the
middle of the board
that is okay very well calculated i
think from magnus in that uh
if black does try to jump forward with
the black knight
top computer suggestions below the
player's cameras and magnet uh hikaru
sorry he does find the best move
that was the only move to keep the game
going everything else would have given
white
a huge decisive advantage so now magnus
has
a threat to deal with white's rook in
the center was under attack he has to
bring it back and now hikaru
hassling white's king side attacking
some pawns
what will magnus come up with it does
feel like magnus may be getting a bit
nervous
uh the position repeats itself magnus
doesn't go for the draw he defends his
rook in the sense at this time
yeah okay but uh causing some chaos here
whoa we see a trade of bishop for night
and
okay hikaru trying trying to confuse
magnus
black's pawn is also attacking the white
rook magnus's face look he
he knows that even if he's still winning
he's lost control
anything could still happen from this
point white's queen
looks nice but she's not helping with
the defense of the white king as ivanka
mentioned earlier
white's king that's the only way that
hikaru will find tricks and magnus
about to go under 10 seconds he attacked
the black queen the black queen forced
back to where
she came from earlier you're shaking his
head yeah
hikaru maybe i think he missed that last
move forcing the black queen back
to a passive square and now wow that is
calm by magnus
he just pushes a pawn it looks like the
left side of the wood is irrelevant but
he's pushed upon there
to secure the white knight hikaru
pushing pawns and both sides actually
advancing their pawns as far as they can
go
but uh okay i think both sides are yeah
there's no time to calculate now
both sides are just trying to play on
instinct and whose instinct will be
better here
magnus his rook was under fire so he
just steps it back one square
he actually gave up the pride and joy of
his position he gave up that pawn but
now black's pieces are tied up and
magnus magnus is the one shaking his
head now
magnus has just had to move his rook
wow okay maybe magnus has missed this
one he's had to give back a rook for a
night
black's knight was threatening the white
queen threatening some pawns
suddenly uh ivanka all better off
anything could happen in this game
magnus he's completely lost his material
advantage
black is the one who's a porn up now
okay magnus calmly just advancing the
white king
i think magnus over the last few moves
he's completely panicked
he saw the clock situation and i was
expecting him to resign earlier right
i thought he was dead lost but okay he
does now attack the white queen
the white queen will have to find a safe
square
i mean magnus if he doesn't win this one
he's had winning positions against
napolita he had a winning position
against giri earlier in the tournament
he failed to finish those guys off
wow they just agree a draw there's still
so much life in the position
hikaru offered to draw and magnus
accepted
magnus he blew that one a miraculous
save by nakamura and look at magnus's
face he knows that was another
missed opportunity in this tournament